so trump since the start of his
re-election campaign which began on the
day that he took office as president
has collected 2.3 million dollars of
money through his
companies from his campaign donors
and the majority of that money has
flowed through trump
tower commercial llc that's the entity
that owns his space inside his famous
fifth avenue tower that's been about one
and a half million dollars that we went
through there
but then there are some other payments
there's a company called trump the trump
corporation
that's collected about 200 000 since the
start
since he took office and those expenses
are very hard to get a
handle on they list them as legal
consulting or i.t consulting
but that company is technically a
management company
there's different random ones that pop
up but the main ones that you see
are trump tower the hotels trump
corporation and trump restaurants llc
so it actually is legal to
spend campaign donor dollars
on your own businesses the trick is that
you have to make sure that you're not
spending more money than the
value of the services that you're
getting so you're not paying an above
market rate
and what's difficult in this situation
we don't know
what they're paying for so if you just
take the
space in trump tower you know they're
paying about 38 000
a month in rent to trump tower but
even though i've asked a bunch of times
they won't tell us how many square feet
they're renting
so if we don't know how many square feet
they're renting we don't know
what type of space it is then we can't
figure out
what the market rate for that space
should be and since we can't figure out
what the market rate should be
we can't tell whether their payments do
fit the market rate
the real comparison here is what we saw
with both the donald j trump foundation
and with the eric trump foundation
where donors were giving money expecting
that they would go
to one thing you know in the case of the
donald j trump
foundation it was you know that it was
gonna go all to charity
and in fact some of that money went to
doing things like you know buying a
signed
uh football helmet from tim tebow or
buying portraits of donald trump
uh that he you know hung up in golf
clubs and in the eric trump foundation
you know it was all supposed to go to uh
a kid's cancer charity and some of that
money
from the donations ended up actually
backing the trump business
uh and so it's it's similar to how
they've
worked with other nonprofits in the past
another example is the presidential
inaugural committee
you know donors were giving funds to the
inauguration some of that money
ended up going back to rent out and
lease space inside the trump
international hotel
and so in all of these instances you
have cases where people
believe that they're donating to one
thing and
some of that money winds up in the trump
family business